[Music]
you believe in virus of course and you
put here you get the view that the
audience gets
[Music]
let's start believin in ghost stories
here n1 pirates franchise is wonderful
characters caught up in this magical
fantastic world we took movie about a
ride and maybe that's about pirates and
the combination of those two is just
captured everybody's imagination and
caring success what I'm going to care of
it
how nice for Pirates of the Caribbean
has become massive editing
and John as Jax Lera I just think he's
extraordinary he created this fantastic
character who became kind of an icon
that everybody loves
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have such fond memories of the first
tree it removed discs on regular meals
[Music]
when you watch the films you get this
feeling this sensation that anything can
happen
just borrow - you know Spirent is here
for its movie has new characters are
going to bring any flavor and a
different dimension to one of the most
powerful fantasies the faltering
- thank you
this movie is so fresh so different so
scary it's a whole reinvention of a
pirates movie
Horrocks life
[Music]
you